moi
j'ai décidé moi je suis pas douée attend
à moi que ces miroirs casimir mon vieux
car je dois vite attendez je ne veux pas
jouer à cache cache parfois laisse moi
terminer ma partie volant avec julie
azimi je ne propose pas de jouer à
cache-cache je te dit de te cacher à
l'airé alors et alors c'est pareil non
casimir cette fois ci c'est sérieux
monsieur travelling revient dans l'île
aux enfants
il fait toujours on est quasiment dans
une cage à travers le monde comme un
horrible et gros monstre oui il faut que
je me passais mes casimir c'est ce que
je me tue à te dire casse toi vite
ou coup attention c'est trop tard je le
vois la rive casimir je suis navré mais
il n'y a pas dans l'île aux enfants ils
nous cachent est assez grande pour un
point gros comme toi je ne suis pas gros
oui d'accord et vous êtes leur saisine
du tram n'est pas gros mais quand même
il faut trouver une solution
diplomatique
attend la voie là bas non merci
vite vite vite je lis et ils ont l'air
très occupé
et moi mes ballons très occupé bien
bonjour monsieur vous voulez quelque
chose oh non vraiment rien pour le
moment non je voudrais simplement savoir
excusez moi je suis très occupé excusez
moi et moi
bonjour monsieur
voulait un joli
mélasse culasses pour jouer au ballon
monsieur je vous arrête tout de suite
ici dans l'île aux enfants tout le monde
à l'âge de jouer au ballon excusez moi
mais j'ai beaucoup de travail non plus
un monsieur plus d'un
mois
alors monsieur on apporte une ans les
commerçants fragile tout pas du tout
mais c'est l'agent je voulais seulement
leur demander un petit renseignement je
ne le savais pas si occupés sinon je ne
me serais pas permis d' un renseignement
très bien il ya 6 voulue renseignements
adressez vous à un agent de police a
bien baissé l'agencé avait entièrement
raison monsieur l'âge alors je réécoute
ah oui et bien voilà monsieur l'agent
j'ai quelque chose de très important à
dire un certain monsieur casimir
pourriez vous me dire où je pourrais le
trouver oui il est du côté de la ramaz
robichon à damas au musée comment fait
on pour les crèches simple vous
traversez le petit bois vous arrivez au
carrefour des lapins bonnet le sentier
de récurrents ya tous droit ensuite à
gauche vous tombez en rocher vous
laissant des ailes à vous demanderez
c'est indiqué d'ailleurs très bien je
vous remercie
mais dites moi nous sommes déjà
rencontrés nous non non non c'est
impossible un assez curieux gtp ce n'est
vous avez déjà vu c'est bizarre c'est
possible
et merci pour le
remplacer c'est ma malle magique dans
les grandes occasions elle se surpasse
toujours et je crois que nous ne sommes
pas prêts de revoir monsieur tran ligne
du site au casino ah non j'ai écouté le
le chemin que tu lui as indiqué il m'a
traversé toute l'île aux enfants
en passant par la montagne
pour monsieur tram ligne je me demande
dans quel état nous allons le retrouver
tout à l'heure
c'est pas drôle donc elle est à nous le
retrouverons
bon soit julie grande nouvelle devinez
ce que j'ai découvert au milieu des
vignes non pas du tout je vous aurais
dit devinez qui j'ai découvert mais
c'est vrai vous avez raison de nous elle
fit eh bien je donne ma langue au chat
bravo c'est très bien bon ça mais il
vous rendez pas compte de 13 ans cette
saison dans l'île aux enfants c'est tous
les jours le printemps il y a toujours
des fraises je vois mais vous êtes si la
long du nerf debout le temps allez dites
moi ce qui vous tracasse et bien tout à
l'heure nous avons très mal reçu
monsieur travelling sans même lui
demander ce qu'il voulait nous l'avons
envoyé chercher casimir à l'autre bout
dit
ce qu'il veut on s'est cherché en est
quasi ni trop peut-être pas nous lui
avons même pas laisser placer un mot le
savons un petit peu perdu la tête il
faut le reconnaître et qu'on dit le
petit chou à la crème de casimir il est
plus ennuyé lui aussi il est parti lui
même à l'autre bout de l'île à sa
recherche dans l'île ils avaient tous
les chemins il va jamais le retrouver
non partant chacun de notre côté et le
premier qui trouve monsieur travelling
le romaine très bonne idée
tata leurs travaux et mes travaux
encore un petit effort
nous sommes arrivés
au je suis je suis je suis épuisé
mais enfin monsieur travail entre nous
pas chercher vous quasi eh bien
eh bien pour lui demander pardon oui je
ne veux plus l'emmener dans un dans une
cage comme ça non je voudrais vivre ici
au milieu de l'île aux enfants enfin je
vais lui parler
mais vous savez que casimir jules et
françois vont revenir et vous savez que
dans l'île aux enfants on adore les
chansons veut bien ce alors venez avec
moi nous allons leur préparer une
surprise
voilà alors elle vient pas de monsieur
travelling moi non plus pourvu qu'il ne
soit pas arrivé un accident cognac
[Musique]
j'ai couru le monde entier
je voulais être milliardaire de l'argent
je le modèle non des chars ils ne me
croyaient s'admirer
vous j'ai compris qu'on ne peut vivre
solitaire
chacun me tester deux mois on se méfiait
j'étais tout seul et je souffrais rien
ne vaut les amis c'est moi qui vous le
dit adieu à solitude
ici je veux rester
votre amitié me plaît gardez moi je suis
vous plaît
je ferai tout du mot pour chasser mais
les faux c'est une certitude
il faut tout partagé parfois
descendre est dit
[Musique]
rien n'est plus beau que l'amitié
voulait et sans pitié
que l'on fasse tous mes caprices pour
tout j'ai décidé jamais je ne serai et
je me croyais respecter
mais tous les gens redoutaient
ma poignée de main est triste
lorsque j'approchais chacun se
détournaient personne ne me salève rien
ne vaut de gagner
il voulait dire
agulla solitude
d
je veux rester votre amitié me plaît
gardez moi s'il vous plaît
je ferai ce qu'il faut pour chasser les
défauts c'est une certitude
il faut tout partager et pas pouvoir et
s'entraider
rien n'est plus beau que l'amitié oui
vos deux amis
moi qui voulais dire adieu la solitude
ici je veux rester votre amitié nos
plaies regardez moi s'il vous plaît
je ferai ce qu'il faut pour chasser les
défauts c'est une certitude
il faut tout partagé parfois des centres
est
rien n'est plus beau que l'amitié
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]